society can't survive without
electricity as this miniature model of
Berlin shows at a glance a real city to
functions only as long as the current
flows but fear of a blackout is growing
especially among people who work in
energy intensive industries for example
if Gaskins energy manager at a rubus
copper the danger of a blackout has
greatly increased simply because the
grid is much more heavily used and is
turned on and off there's much more
traffic on the energy highway Autobahn
is renewable energies are part of the
problem the wind doesn't blow and the
Sun doesn't shine at a constant rate
power grid fluctuations used to require
10 to 20 interventions a year now
thousands are needed but Yann Holman
from the federal Power Authority says
the problem is manageable it's true the
whole system is under greater stress
than it would be without the renewable
energy sources but I think it's
exaggerated to invoke the Bugaboo of a
major blackout if the energy supply
breaks down that not only cuts off
lighting television the telephone system
and heating it also means water stops
flowing automatic teller machines stop
working looting and violence could
explode even after only a short time if
the electricity really goes off then
chaos breaks out rather quickly in a
major blackout the economy would
collapse factories would shut down and
so would every office that uses modern
communications and computer technology
the economy and all of society are
highly dependent on electricity
almost a blue piezoelectricity is the
bloodstream of the economy if it fails
the economy is paralyzed and of course
that would mean substantial losses to
the gross domestic product companies
that use lots of energy like Aruba's
copper suffer even from short lived
power fluctuations they produce copper
that is also needed for building
windmills solar collectors and expanding
the electrical grid the blast furnaces
at Aruba's have to operate without
interruption for example if it were a
blackout in the winter the copper would
solidify and would have to be removed
from the equipment by hand
that's why Aruba's has purchased backup
generators they would keep the copper
hot production couldn't continue but
losses could be limited and they
threatened to incur even with minor
current fluctuations Shula Island vissa
even a brownout of just a few hours
costs us a few hundred thousand euros
the power failed and we didn't have our
backup generators then we'd be talking
about losses in the double-digit
millions so Germany's federal electrical
grid agency understands the fear of
blackouts it regards an expansion of the
grid as a way of getting a handle on
current fluctuations but it also appeals
to companies sense of responsibility for
themselves company is such a sensitive
production system that it has to bridge
power interruptions that lasts only
milliseconds which are completely normal
and have always happened then it ought
to have its own emergency power
generator today every hospital has one
so much I'd also want the agency says
the population is not endangered on the
contrary says home on Germany's energy
supply is very secure in comparison with
other countries I wouldn't say it's the
most secure in the world but it's one of
the most secure
will that reassure Afghans of Aruba's of
course if there is a blackout everything
will be done to restore power as fast as
possible renewable energy sources
complicate things but a major blackout
is not in the offing